tragedy coming out of california this
weekend police arresting one suspect
after a shooting in sacramento left six
people dead and a dozen others injured
president biden wasting no time though
to push his anti-gun agenda saying quote
we must do more than mourning we must
act that is why my administration has
taken historic executive action to
implement my comprehensive gun crime
reduction strategy
biden calling on congress to ban ghost
guns assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines as well as require background
checks for all gun sales and repeal gun
manufacturers immunity from liability
but just remember this california has
already some of the toughest gun laws
in the entire country uh you you were
kind of shaking your head disapproval
while i was reading the biden statement
not at you
but about him so and in our first block
we showed when he got off the helicopter
and he comes to talk about the
atrocities in bucharest and the first
thing he says is well i was criticized
and it's all about him right so like how
about standing up and having a moment of
just like this will not stand there's
something but it had to be about how i
was criticized but i was right and then
the first thing he does after this is
that oh um let me pull out my statement
that i have already written up with all
the things i've already done to say that
it's not my fault because i promo i
propose all of these things rather can
you ever just have a moment of saying
this is a tragedy but dianne feinstein
put out a tweet and she said here's all
the things that we need well guess what
those things already exist so the laws
aren't the laws that are on the books
are not effective
and the prosecutions as we've been
talking about here for a few for several
months we know that those aren't
happening and so those moms and the
siblings and the aunts and uncles that
are
crying today because of this
unimaginable tragedy that's happened to
their family
everyone should look to the prosecutors
i think to make sure that they're
actually prosecuting the crimes and
making sure that those criminals aren't
on the street yeah and this guy beat his
wife greg this uh guy they just arrested
and it looks like all the shell casings
these were handguns
i don't know uh i was just thinking when
you were talking about uh president
biden uh you know the first block he
just called putin a war criminal why
didn't he just condemn
missile crime
right i mean in a weird thing when it
comes to the when it comes to any kind
of gun crime he excuses the individual
responsibility of the criminal in fact
that's it's not it's also with knife
crime now there's like that somehow this
knife just magically shows up in some
homeless maniacs hand we're we're gonna
go back to that familiar back and forth
that we had pre-pandemic which is you'll
you'll have a shooting followed by cries
for gun control in areas with the
strictest gun control measures right and
then you sit there and you go like well
where have all these people been for the
past two years while they ignored other
kinds of crime whether it was gang
violence whether it was smash and grabs
whether it was riots they had no
interest in reducing violence because
they already would have responded to
that what about the random attacks on
jews and asians so biden chooses crime
that could be easily satisfied with lazy
platitudes about gun makers because that
always is the end of the effort it's
like
evil nra evil guns and then they just
move on but it's going to be it's
pointless gun control is dead because of
the last two years of defund rhetoric
the nationalized ferguson effect that
was caused by the riots you could simul
you you can't simultaneously return
reduce a person's right to protect
themselves while also getting rid of
cops so gun control is dead
janine
is it dead
the problem with biden is he would
rather get involved in amending a
constitutional amendment the second
amendment that's been affirmed by the
supreme court repeatedly then call on
police or call on legislators to get rid
of this uh this in and out of the
criminal justice system where there's no
bail there that they're you know they're
all released to commit another crime and
in truth i mean nobody's being
prosecuted we've got da's like escond in
la and you've got uh the other one
boudin in san francisco i believe it is
and you know now he wants to go after
the gun manufacturers will go after the
car manufacturers for drunk drivers and
he wants background checks i love it i
was a prosecutor i did this the
background checks are those are not the
guns that are involved in crime the guns
that are involved in criminal behavior
and my 32 years in law enforcement
except for one were guns that were sold
illegally or bought on the street these
are not guns by law-abiding people who
went out and bought a gun unless they're
using their mothers or sisters or
someone else's gun so put them in jail
and you won't have to change the
constitution let me guess harold you see
things a little bit differently than the
rest of the table
so i think you'll be surprised i think
first off um
we should reform the bail laws that
should be
the president should have said that as a
part of what he said yesterday
two you have to give him credit the
president said we will increase funding
for the police he never
uh sided with the defunded police effort
there clearly was an element in my party
uh that espoused some of that and i was
against that and he was against it i do
think in fairness if you look at some of
the things he's talking about and you
raise the right point judge it's the
ghost guns he wants to ban him i think
we ought to have a very serious robust
debate about what a ghost gun is and
what steps can we take to ensure
that we reduce the number of those on
the streets look we've not had a van
ghost gun or require background checks
for all gun cells we've had ban we've
had a ban on assault weapons we've not
repealed the gunfire gun gun
manufacturers immunity from liability
maybe we should do these things and if
it doesn't work repeal it i mean i'm
honest about it be happy to say the bail
reform is not working it's letting
criminals back out on the street and
it's causing danger increasing danger
and threats in communities all across
this nation should be repealed we should
do more of some of this gun stuff here
especially the ghost guns if we did
nothing else if you knew a gun that
someone bought got stolen or you person
was buying tens if not dozens if not
hundreds of guns and they were just
disappearing and all of a sudden
appearing in chicago in memphis in new
york in denver new orleans in atlanta
and baltimore we got to go that gun said
did you think those 250 guns you bought
did you think that maybe since they were
end up in the hands of criminals and
gang bankers did you ever think that
something was wrong it's oh i didn't
know that person should be held
accountable as much as anything else and
you're right the president should have
said um we got to hold those accountable
who use guns we ought to prosecute
people and give people the funding
to put people behind bars who are using
guns well they're not prosecuting a lot
of gun crimes on the federal level under
this administration they did a lot more
under the trump administration a lot
under this administration hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else